hi my name is sam buss this is the first
of four lectures in the proof complexity
morning for the satisfyability boot camp
held the simon's institute
in this lecture we'll discuss
introductory topics including
fraga proofs and then abstract proof
systems
then resolution and then finally
extended resolution
and extended fraca systems to start off
with the
really introductory material let's
describe what propositional formulas are
so for propositional formulas or
sometimes called boolean formulas
variables range over true false values
and we denote variables
x y z or sometimes p and q
a literal is either a variable or the
negation of a variable
we could either write that as a not x or
with over line
to mean negation so over line x means
the same thing as not x and
double over line x is actually just the
same as
x in general we're going to form our
propositional formulas
from connectives starting with either
variables or literals
allowing connectives such as and and or
or
if then or not and i'll use
lowercase greek letters like phi and psi
to describe formulas
and one special case of formulas of the
so-called conjunctive normal form
formulas cnf formulas or disjunctive
normal form formulas
dnf formulas a conjunctive normal form
formula is a formula which is
expressible as an and
of wars of literals a dnf formula is a
formula which is a
or of ands of literals
a very crucial concept for us is the
notion of a satisfiable formula
or unsatisfiable formula in particular
we define a formula to be a tautology
if every truth assignment makes v true
so a truth assignment means assigning
true false valuables to the variables
then we evaluate the truth value of the
formula using the usual meaning of
connect
such as and or if then and not
and a tautology is one where no matter
how we assign
truth values to the variables v
evaluates to true
in this case we also say fee is valid a
formula is satisfiable
if there's some truth assignment that
makes v true
and an elementary observation is that
fee is unsatisfiable
if only if not v is valid or is a
tautology
the point being that fee is
unsatisfiable means no truth assignment
makes be true and therefore every truth
assignment makes
not v true and therefore not phi is a
tautology
and it's a classic result due to steve
cook that it's n p hard and even
np complete determine the satisfiability
of a formula fee and
it's co np complete to determine the
validity of a formula fee
steve actually showed that it's np
complete and thus np
hard to determine the satisfiability of
a conjunctive normal form formula
uh and it's also np hard to determine
the validity
of a dnf formula so it's co np complete
to do that
now one of the crucial tasks in computer
science and many things is to
establish satisfiability or
unsatisfiability of a formula so one way
to establish satisfiability is to give a
satisfying assignment
so this is like a small witness it shows
that satisfiability is np
for unsatisfiability one way to
establish
unsatisfiability is to give a proof of
not fee
so a proof of not fee establishes that
not fee is valid is a tautology
and thus the fee is unsatisfiable
so this lets us turn to proof systems to
talk about
establishing unsatisfiability
so the first proof system here is frag
approved systems
and this one will be a proof system that
proves
formulas as compared to a proof system
which refutes formulas
it's a fragra proof system also
denoted with a with an f sign is a
textbook style propositional proof
system and i'll take it have modus
ponens as its only rule of inference for
the moment
variables range over true false values
the connectives
can be for instance not and or and if
then
modus ponens is then the rule of
inference from v and v implies psi
you can infer psi and the standard
axiomization
one of them is listed here there's many
possible aximizations
so here's the first five standard axiom
schemes
for a commonly used phrase system the
first one says that
fee implies psi implies v which if then
groups from right to left so that means
that v implies the formula sign implies
v
and the next four formulas also mean
uh similar things like the last one is b
and psi implies psi
and it's easy to check that no matter
how you substitute in formulas
for fee and psi the resulting formulas
listed here as an axiom scheme
are valid they're always true and it's
called a scheme because
it's a framework where you can
substitute any formula for fee
psi and and chi in the second axiom
now this system f although i didn't
fully define it is
sound and complete in fact it's
implicationally sound and
implicationally complete so let me say
what these mean
a form of f is sound
means that whenever you have a fragra
proof of a formula fee
fee is valid so the phraga system only
proves valid formulas
it's complete in that any valid formula
fee
has a fragra proof there's also a
stronger notions
of soundness and completeness known is
implicational soundness and
implicational completeness
uh so in this case we assume we have a
set of formulas
gamma and we use the formulas in gamma
as a set of hypotheses
and then given the gamma formulas
as initial formulas the formula
fee has a proof
in the phaga system from those
hypotheses if and only if
v is logically implied
by the hypotheses so this symbol here
gamma double turn style fee means that
any truth assignment
that makes every formula in gamma true
also makes
v true
these are very basic theorems the
soundness
theorems are almost immediate from the
fact that the inferences
are chosen so as to preserve truth and
the axiom schemes are chosen to be valid
and
for a completeness theorem we can
formalize the method of truth tables
within a fragra proof
in other words a frag of proof can try
out all possible truth assignments
and verify that a formula is true under
all of them
so i should add here as a side remark
that although i discussed one phraga
system
as listed on the previous slide in fact
there's a whole family of phraga systems
you can take any
finite complete set of boolean
connectives and any finite set of axiom
schemes and rule schemes
and assuming that those axioms
and rules provide an implicationally
sound and implicationally complete
system
we call it a fraga proof system
so we are
interested in the complexity of proofs
and our most
common way of measuring the complexity
of proofs is what we call
size and the size of a proof in
particular size of a fraga proof
is the number of symbols in the proof
and we write
f single turn styles m
v to mean that phi has a fragra proof
of size m a fragra proof with and most m
symbols
and the size of a formula written with
absolute value signs
the size of the formula is the number of
symbols and formula
now as just mentioned on the previous
slide every tautology has
a fragra proof however the
proof method that we used for the
completeness was to use the method of
truth tables and method of truth tables
meant going through all possible truth
assignments
and checking that each one made fee true
there's
in general a formula fee of size
n may have nearly n
or some small constant times n many
different variables so there may be
close to exponential or
two to some small constant times n many
truth assignments
so this completeness theorem gives us
exponential size proofs in general
and as a fundamental and very important
open question
is is there a polynomial p of n
such that every tautology fee has a
figure proof of size
less than or equal to p of n where n is
the size of v
such a if this holds we would call fraga
polynomially bounded so again
the completeness proof showed the
existence of exponential size proofs for
valid formulas the open problem is is
there a
fixed polynomial such that all formula
all valid formulas of size m have a
fragra proof of size less than or equal
to p of n
as it turns out the answer is the same
for always of all different ways of
formalizing fraga systems we happen to
use
modus ponens in a particular set of 10
axiom schemes
but it wasn't all that important we used
that particular set of axiom schemes
because
all different phraga systems p simulate
each other
in the sense i'll describe next meaning
that a proof in one type of phraga
system can be
transformed into a proof in a different
phraga system
so this brings up the notion of
measuring the sizes of proofs in a more
abstract way
so this definitions due to
cook and cooking recall an abstract
proof system
is a polynomial time function f
mapping the set of binary strings 0 1
star
onto the set of tautologies
so when we're defining an abstract proof
system we fix a
language in the sense of a set of
boolean connectives a finite set of
boolean connectives
and we now want a polynomial time
function which maps
strings over zero one onto the set of
tautologies
a f proof now this is lowercase f
w is a boolean string such that
little f of w is phi
so in other words we the image of f is a
set of tautologies
and the pre-image of a topology is a
proof
of that tautology the size of the proof
w
is the number of binary symbols zero
zeros and ones in w
the length of w now this sounds like a
fairly
non-intuitive way to define a proof
system but let's it's also a very
general way
and in particular let's look at how to
describe the fraga proof system
as an abstract proof system we define a
function
f sub f little f sub fraga of w
to be the following if the last line of
w is the formula
is a formula fee and if w
is a valid fragra proof
then f sub f of w is equal to the last
line of w
if w is not a valid figure proof or not
an encoding of a valid figure proof
then we'll just punt as it were choose
some arbitrary variable x
and let f sub f of w be the tautology
x or not x
so it's clear that f sub f
is a proof system it always outputs
tautologies
and since every tautology has a fragra
proof
every tautology is in the range of f sub
f
it's also clear that this didn't depend
very much on the phraga system f
it's a very abstract way to describe it
and so for instance you could take very
strong systems such as zf set theory
as an abstract proof system and
basically the way this would work as you
would
f sub zf would take in a string w if
it's an encoding
of a valid z f proof of the statement
quote
v is a tautology in some appropriate
encoding of that statement
then f sub z f of w would output v
so extremely strong proof systems can be
defined
and but observation due to
cook and recall and is there's a
polynomially bounded abstract
proof system if and only if np
equals co np so
the proof idea for this theorem is based
on the fact that the set of tautologies
is
co-np complete so
if np equals co np
then you can take an np representation
of the tautologies
as accepted by some non-deterministic
polynomial time turing machine
and you can let accepting computations
of that turing machine
serve as proofs in the abstract
proof system right
conversely if the set of tautologies all
have short proofs
you can let those short proofs serve as
witnesses
of membership in the co-mp complete set
of tautologies
so that's that's the proof sketch in a
nutshell
and this proves that the theorem that
there's some polynomially bounded
abstract proof system if and only if np
equals co and p
a few more basic definitions if
f and g are abstract proof systems we
say that f
simulates g if there is a polynomial q
of n such that whenever
g of some string w equals some formula
phi
then there's a v such that
v is polymerally bounded where the
length of v
is pulmonary bounded by the length of w
and such that f of v
equals w equals f of v equals phi
intuitively this means that any g proof
of v
any g proof w of v can be
converted into an f proof
a fee with size only polynomially larger
now simulates doesn't say anything about
how you would get v from w
there's another notion of f p simulates
g
if there's a polynomial time computable
function
h of w such that whenever g of w equals
v
we have f of h of w equals v in other
words we have a polynomial time method
to get the f proof v
of v and to repeat an earlier definition
is f is polynomially bounded if for some
polynomial q of n
every tautology phi has a f proof of
size less than equal to q
of the length of v so between
simulate and p simulate we have a way of
measuring the relative strengths of
proof systems in terms of the lengths of
their proofs
so as i already mentioned item one here
any two fragra proof systems p simulate
each other
uh yeah a little bit of care needs to be
taken with a statement if they use
different languages but you can make
sense out of this by having a natural
way of translating formulas
in one language into the other language
it's also open whether there's any
abstract proof system
which simulates or p simulates all
abstract proof systems
and it's open whether there's a
polynomially bounded abstract proof
system
just to mention in passing one result
here about abstract proof systems these
maximality of abstract proof systems
a theorem of prior check and put lock is
that if
exponential time is equal to
nondeterministic exponential time
then there's an abstract proof system
which p simulates
every abstract proof system and if
non-deterministic exponential time is
closed under complement
then there's an abstract proof system
which simulates
every abstract proof system
so to put a little bit of history in
here
a lot of what i've talked about so far
is what's known as cook's
program from the work of steve cook and
robert reckow
cook's program can be loosely stated as
let's try to prove np is not equal to
co-np
by proving there's no polynomially
bounded propositional proof system
so this was formulated in the mid 70s
and here's a
chart taken from robert's recall's phd
thesis
showing the state of the art back then
so in this picture
there's a dashed line here and there's a
bunch of systems below the dashed line
starting with the method of truth tables
and moving upward through
analytic tableau and the davis-putnam
procedure and regular
resolution which i'll define those later
and above the dashed line were systems
such as
the cut frequency system resolution
fraga systems which i've talked about
and
resolution with extension which i'll
talk about later in the talk
and at in the mid seventies the state of
the art was that the systems
below the dashed line were known to not
be
polynomially bounded in that we had
examples of
propositional formulas that were valid
but required
super polynomial the super polynomially
long proofs in these systems
and the systems above the the line it
was open whether or not they were
pulmonary bounded or not
so here's a update
to pretty much the current state of
knowledge i took this from a 2015
talk but no systems have moved across
any lines here
here is a bunch of the dashed line has
moved up
to the red shorter dashed line and
in the meantime again some systems
without cut and resolution
had both been shown to not be
pollenly bounded i'll talk about the
result for
resolution in this part b of this series
of talks
also in the meantime a bunch of other
systems have come in to study
there's the constant depth vega systems
where you have constant alternations of
ands and ors
there's constant depth fragrance systems
with some mod m
counting axioms there's a system known
as cutting planes
another algebraic system is known as
nostalgia and polynomial calculus
and uh cutting planes works with
linear integer inequalities nordstell
and zots and
polynomial calculus deal with equations
over fields
and these will get discussed in part d
of this talk
but all of these systems i wrote them
here below the
dashed red line are known not to be
pollenally bounded there's some
citations here
um it's a
bit out of date there's been quite a bit
of work on these systems since 2015.
especially the bottom three cutting
planes no stellensense
and palm maybe calculus
but this is sort of where we are with
the
cooks program here the minute we hit
phraga systems which you'll see sitting
right here
we no longer know whether or not the
system is polybounded and it's entirely
possible
to our current state of knowledge that
every tautology has a polynomial size
proof
in a fraca system
so this whole notion of simulations and
piece simulations
is very natural it makes a nice
hierarchy a kind of a lattice
on propositional proof systems and
gives you a good way to compare the
strength of proof systems but they
suffer in applications
from the fact that they do not account
for the difficulty of searching for
proofs
in satisfiability we're often interested
not just in
some sort of theoretical thing about
does a proof exist but
can we find it and the difficulty
of this proof search process is often
more important than
bounds on the lengths of proofs so
indeed it's often preferable to search
for proofs
in a weaker system that admits effective
proof search
procedures than to search for proofs in
a stronger system
where there may be shorter proofs so a
prime example of this
and it forms the foundation for a
huge number of on automated theorem
proving stuff
especially in the domain of
satisfiability is the system resolution
and some of its subsystems
these resolution is weaker in the sense
of simulation than something like fragus
systems
but it will be easier to search for
proofs in resolution than it is to
search for proofs in a fragrant proof
system
so resolution i'll go pretty fast on
this since i think
most of the audience to these slides
knows this
resolution is a so-called refutation
system
it refutes sets of clauses that is it
shows that
the set of clauses is unsatisfiable a
clause
a set of clauses is the same thing as a
conjunctive normal form formula
each clause is a disjunction of literals
the set of clauses is the and of those
clauses
and so when we refute a cnf formula this
is the same thing
as proving that a dnf formula is a
tautology
so remember showing that a cnf formula
is unsatisfiable is the same thing as
showing its negation namely a dnf
formula
is valid so we can either view
resolution as a refutation system for
cnf formulas
or a proof system for dnf formulas
so to give the formal definition of
resolution a literal is either variable
or negated variable
a clause is a set of literals
interpreted as their disjunction as
their or
a set gamma clause is a c and formula
and there's
one rule of inference which is from
x or c and from
not x or d we can infer c
or d so here i'm writing clauses
as sets commas can be interpreted as
either and or union
and so we have two clauses as hypotheses
they one contains x the other contains x
bar
not x and we resolve on the variable x
removing
x and keeping the rest of the clauses a
resolution refutation then is a
derivation
starting with clauses in gamma that ends
up with the empty clause
the empty clause is the empty
disjunction the empty disjunction is the
same thing as the constant false
so in this way if we can
derive the constant false from a set of
clauses it cannot be possible to
up to simultaneously satisfy all the
clauses in the set gamma
so well-known fact and pretty basic for
this
is that resolution is sound and complete
for of course refuting sets of clauses
so soundness is not hard
to prove for you just can prove that
in a resolution inference if the
conclusion is false under some truth
assignment then one of the hypotheses is
false under some truth assignment
for a completeness you can use the davis
putnam procedure
so this was um this was
introduced by a paper by davis and
putnam in 1960
also the paper that was not the first
time resolution was defined
that was in the 1920s but it was started
the modern use of
resolution now the davis putnam
procedure is the following you choose
one variable as your resolution variable
you look at all the clauses that contain
either x or not x
you resolve all possible pairs of these
clauses together
you obtain clauses that don't contain x
or not x
and then we discard once we finish that
we discard the clauses that contain
extra not x
and then we iterate choosing another
variable and doing the same thing
this procedure can certainly take
exponential time to carry out
and but it it will if the original set
of clauses is unsatisfiable it will in
the end eliminate all variables ending
up with the
empty clause um
this is for refutations resolution this
theorem first theorem was for
refutations
resolution as a refutation system
there's also a kind of completeness
theorem for deriving clauses namely if
gamma logically implies
c and that should really be a
double turn style there
there is a sub clause d of c
and there's a resolution derivation of d
from gamma in other words there's a
sequence of resolution inferences
that takes you starting with clauses in
gamma and produces the clause d
and this second theorem can also be
proved via the davis putnam procedure
namely resolving on all variables
that do not occur in c one at a time
so one more definition that will be
useful later on is
a regular resolution proof
a for this a resolution derivation can
be
viewed as a sequence of clauses and each
clause as we've discussed is either
hypothesis
that's a input clause from the set i
called gamma or is inferred by
resolution from earlier clauses
and as a sequence of clauses of this
type it defines
a dag a directed acyclic graph on the
clauses in the derivation
and definition going back to satan 68
who was one of the first ones to talk
about complexity proofs in this
setting a resolution refutation is
regular
if there's no path in the refutation dag
on which the same variable is resolved
on
more than once and
a theorem not hard to show is that
regular resolution is complete
in fact the davis putnam procedure just
outlined on the previous slide gives
regular refutations
so regular resolution comes up
as a tool in many practical proof search
things and we'll see this
in a later talk but it is weaker
than resolution this took some time to
be proved but
um in about 2002 electorovich johansson
potassium proved
that regular resolution does not
simulate resolution
in other words there are some
unsatisfiable sets of clauses such that
their shortest resolution refutation
is much shorter than their shortest
regular resolution refutation
so let's return to how to do resolutions
an abstract proof system
so i was talking about resolution
as a proof system for dnf formulas a
refutation system for cnf formulas the
hensa
proof system for dnf formulas but the
way we define
abstract proof systems is supposed to be
a proof system for
all propositional formulas and
resolution
can't use all propositional formulas
each line
in a resolution refutation or resolution
derivation is a clause
each clause is just a disjunction but
we're sort of implicitly maintaining a
big set of clauses so
at each point resolution has a set of
clauses that it's working with
so it's working with a cnf formula but
it's not working with an
arbitrary propositional formula with
ands and ors
arbitrarily nested so satan
proposed a method to take care of this
so-called extension rule
so extension lets you
add a new variable
which is an abbreviation for a previous
formula
so formally we take two literals x and y
and we let z be a new variable that
hasn't been used anywhere
and we introduce z as an abbreviation as
it were
for the formula x and y by adding three
new clauses
we take x bar y bar z
z bar x and z bar y
so this means z bar y means the same as
not z or y
hence z implies y z bar x means
z implies x and x bar y bar z
means not x or not y or z
which means the same thing as x and y
implies z
hence these three clauses mean the same
thing as z
if and only if x and y and a dual
construction works fine to introduce x
or y
so if we want to view resolution as an
abstract proof system
if we're given a propositional formula
fee
let's assume it's fully parenthesized we
introduce
clauses for all the extension variables
z sub phi that represent the sub
formulas
v of z sub sub all the extension
variables e sub psi
that represent the sub formula psi of v
so in other words starting with the
smallest sub formula sign working our
way up to the entire
formula fee we introduce
z sub psi as being either the
conjunction or disjunction of two
earlier variables
or two earlier literals
and in this way we introduce exactly
what's needed to represent the sub
formulas of fee
with variables and then if we take the
following set of clauses
we have this the clauses in
gamma the new extension variable that
define the new extension variables
and the singleton clause not z of phi
this not z sub phi this expresses the
negation of v
and then we can say that a resolution
proof of phi
is the same thing as a resolution of
mutation of the singleton
not z sub phi and the set of clauses
gamma
so satan introduced the extension rule
as a way to um
to talk about resolution as a proof
system for arbitrary propositional
formulas
but resolution rule for the extension
rule
is also just a very useful rule in its
own right
and when we add this we get a system
known as
extended resolution and we'll also add
it to
frag systems and get extended phragus
and get extended proof extended fraga
proofs
so the proof system extended resolution
is resolution where you augment the
unrestricted use of the extension rule
in other words not just using extension
for sub formulas of the formula fee to
be proved
but allowing the use of the extension
rule for any formula
and so this means at any point in the
proof we can take some existing literals
x and y
pick a new variable z and introduce the
three clauses expressing that z
is equivalent to x and y
in the frag system we have a
more general way of doing the same thing
the extension rule for the frag system
allows introducing new variables
standing for arbitrary formulas
so at any point in a fragra proof we
could have a
as a new formula appearing in the proof
we have the formula z if and only if phi
and this is probably an abbreviation for
z implies v
and v implies z since that was the
connectives i was using for the fragra
proof system
but we get a formula expressing this
property z has to be a new variable
in the sense it's not been used anywhere
in the earlier part of the proof
it does not appear in the formula fee
and nor does it appear in the last line
of the proof
and this then gives the notion of
extended phraga
systems and a fairly intuitive theorem
at least
is that extended resolution and extended
fraga
p simulate each other in that
any extended resolution proof can be
translated into an extended fingerproof
and conversely and extended fragra proof
can be translated into an extended
resolution proof and these translations
can be carried out
feasibly in polynomial time
and the general idea of transforming
an extended figure proof into an
extended resolution proof
is just as follows the extended fragra
proof can have
complex formulas it may not just have
clauses for instance but what we can do
is we can introduce for every complex
formula in the extent of fragra proof
we can introduce a new variable and then
the extended resolution can work with
the new variables
and keep the size of the formula is
simple
now there's a nice way to understand
extended fraga
proof complexity in terms of fraga proof
complexity
but we're going to relate the size of
extended fragra proofs
to the number of steps or the number of
formulas the number of lines
in a fragra proof so
earlier we defined proof size v dash m
the mean proof size measured in terms of
the number of symbols appearing in the
proof
we can also measure proof size in terms
of the numbers of
inference steps denoted i'll just v
dash m steps and so this means that
there's
m steps in the proof or m distinct lines
or indistinct occurrences of formulas
in the proof and
nice theorem of stamin is that if we
have a phraga proof with
m steps of a formula fee then that same
formula fee has an extended figure proof
of size linear in m and
the length of fee squared so it's order
m
plus the length of v squared
and the general idea for this proof is
as follows
if f has m steps in it it
could have very long formulas in it thus
making large size
but if we could keep the proof to have m
steps but keep all the formulas
small then
uh while getting the extended figure
proof then we get the bound we want
so the idea is to introduce whenever we
look at the fragra proof and whenever it
starts introducing
large formulas we reduce the size of
those large formulas by introducing
new variables using extension to stand
for its sub formulas
and by carrying this idea carefully you
can get that the
m-steps of the fragra proof turn into
order m steps order m symbols i should
say
an extended figure proof that is order m
steps but each line has
constantly many symbols the length of
fee squared term is because in the end
you have to
unwind v to get rid of the extension
variables
representing the sub formulas of v and
that could in the worst case bring in
quadratically many symbols
another way to think about fraga versus
extended fragra
is in terms of boolean formulas versus
boolean circuits
so with the fragra proof
looking at this first bullet point here
is a proof in which each line is a
boolean
formula or propositional formula we can
view an extended fragra proof
as a proof in which each line is a
boolean circuit and the point is
if you have a boolean circuit that means
instead of being a formula it's a
directed a sickly graph
the inputs to the graph are variables
the nodes inside the graph are boolean
gates
and uh we can introduce an extension
variable
for each gate in the circuit and thus
get
a polynomial size way of representing
the valid
the value of the circuit by
defining the value of the circuit with
an extension variable
uh that using iteratively the extension
rule to define the value of each gate
so in this way we get the intuition that
we a fragile proof is a proof in which
each line's a boolean formula
an extended fragrance proof is a proven
which each line is a boolean circuit
you can make this intuition rigorous
and emily robick has done so in a system
called circuit fraga
but i'm going to skip that here and just
remark that
we have two conjectures that are made
one on the complexity side and the other
on the proof complexity side
the first conjectures the boolean
circuits cannot be converted into
polynomial size
boolean formulas and two equivalent
polynomial size building formulas
the second conjecture is that the phraga
systems
do not simulate or psimulate extended
fragus systems
and the these are
somehow analogous because it seems like
frag and extended fragrance proofs
reason respectively about boolean
formulas and boolean circuits
so it's tempting to say that these
conjectures should be equivalent but
there's actually no known direct
connection between these conjectures
on one hand formulas might be able to
polynomially represent circuits
but this conversion of circuits into
polynomial size formulas
may not be approval with fragra proofs
so even though
things are expressible we may not be
able to prove the properties that we
need
conversely there might be some
completely different other method
for fraga to assimilate extended fraga
that does not involve
converting circuits to formulas so
neither of these possibilities can be
ruled out
nonetheless it makes a nice way to think
about
and to motivate fraga versus extended
figure proofs
so our current state of the art just to
run through some review here
is any two frag approved systems piece
simulate each other
um likewise any two extended fraga proof
systems p simulate each other
it's clear just trivially that extended
frago systems p simulate fragrance
systems
it on the other hand it's open whether
fragus systems simulate extended
fragrance systems
it's open whether either of these
systems is polynomially bounded
uh already mentioned that extended
resolution extended fragrance systems
pieces simulate each other
it should be clear that fragrance
systems p simulate
red resolution on the other hand and
we'll see later that resolution does not
simulate fragis systems
and already mentioned that regular
resolution does not simulate resolution
so in the talks going forward in
particular the next two talks are part b
and part c and they can be watched
independently of each other
part b will discuss what's known about
separating resolution
frag and extended fragrance systems
especially using the pigeon principle
and part c will discuss resolution and
its subsystems
and how they relate to conflict
uh conflict directed clause learning
cdcl proof search
and part d will discuss yet further
approved systems
so this is the end of part a and before
you depart
let me just mention there's several
survey articles available to read um
including one that the very top one
there that's just coming out
i think approximately this month uh in
early 2021
uh by jacob nordstrom and myself
on proof complexity